welcome everybody uh you all know that i
have no interest whatsoever no intention
whatsoever no motivation whatsoever
to deceive you about the believability
or the trustworthiness of anybody but in
particular in the context of the january
6 committee investigating the trump
riots
i have no interest in telling you that a
witness is any more or less credible
than they actually are
and in a few minutes we're going to look
at a specific claim made by former aide
to former trump chief of staff mark
meadows
cassidy hutchinson we're going to look
at a specific claim she made that's
being disputed and we will discuss is
this plausible who do we think is
telling the truth we're going to look at
that and she may have said something
that wasn't true
we'll figure it out
but
first we have to talk about these brazen
and completely baseless smears that have
launched against cassidy hutchinson and
it's a really great insight into how a
propaganda outlet
in this case breitbart the right-wing
propaganda outlet breitbart can generate
what looks like a news story based on
nothing
headline from this morning breitbart
report cassidy hutchinson fabricated
testimony about conversation with former
white house counsel pat chipoloni
whoa
report this must be pretty serious
you start reading the article and you
will very quickly see what this is about
the article reads cassidy hutchinson a
former white house aide who was the
january 6th committee star witness
during a surprise hearing
held on tuesday
reportedly fabricated pieces of her
testimony about conversations she had
with former white house counsel patrick
bologna okay
during her testimony hutchinson claimed
that chipoloni told her to tell her boss
chief of staff mark meadows that former
president trump should not go to the
capitol on january 6th
that's true she did testify to that
hutchinson testified chipoloni said
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable if trump went to the
capitol the committee's vice chair liz
cheney doubled down on her calls to get
tripoloni to testify before the
committee due to hutchinson's testimony
as we heard yesterday white house
counsel pat chipoloni had significant
concerns about trump's activities on
january 6th cheney tweeted it's time for
mr chipoloni to testify on the record
any concerns he has about the
institutional interests of his prior
officer outweighed by the need for his
testimony that's true they are now they
have now subpoenaed patchapoloni and we
will get to that
but then it starts to get a little weird
the breitbart article reads however
chipoloni was reportedly not at the
white house on the morning of january
6th
according to human events senior editor
jack pozobiak
and then you look what is the source of
this report and it is tweets from a
conspiracy theorist jack posobiac
that's the source
jack posobiac tweeted
apropos of nothing citing no sources
breaking
multiple sources including one who was
at the white house on january 6
tell me
chipoloni was not there in the am when
hutchinson testified she spoke with him
january 6 committee is aware of this
discrepancy and are ignoring media
inquiries about it
seems she made up the entire
conversation
okay
this is an example of the collapse of
journalism now remember i don't do
journalism i do commentary i'm not a
reporter okay and so when i tell you
where am i getting a story
i tell you i'm getting this from a news
reporting agency or i'm getting this
from an opinion person or whatever the
case may be
breitbart claims to be doing news and
reporting
and when you look
they are just citing a tweet from a
conspiracy theorist
that's it that's the whole basis
anybody who has worked at an actual
journalism institution would know
there are standards and practices and no
serious journalism outfit
would publish such a story
based on a tweet from a conspiracy
theorist that's all it is that's all
that this is there's nothing there
there's just nothing there and when
someone in trump's orbit
is trying to
gather information to discredit a
witness
and everybody's insisting on anonymity
and none of them actually show up to
testify under oath and maybe some of
them will and then i'll change my
perspective when you publish something
like this
you are you are becoming a node
or in a signal booster of disinformation
and by the way it's disinformation all
in the service of defending and running
interference for those who tried to
convert completely subvert
the democracy of the united states but i
guess it generates clicks i don't know
now
if secret service wants to testify under
oath
whatev if they want to do that then
let's listen to them and then we will
have two competing under oath statements
to evaluate and compare
okay
right now
we have the under oath testimony of
cassidy hutchinson and then we have you
know unsourced tweets
vague statements about we would be
willing to dispute elements of her
testimony but nobody's actually shown up
under oath despite being invited by the
january 6 committee
so that's what this is this is ponscum
now let's get to a more substantive
claim about something cassidy hutchinson
said which is being uh
contradicted specifically and narrowly
okay so
let's now move away from the unsourced
conspiracy smears against cassidy
hutchinson the january 6 committee
witness and let's look at a specific
claim that's being made about something
she said that is allegedly not true
there are now reports
that the note that was put up on the
screen during cassidy hutchinson's
testimony which she said i wrote that
that's my handwriting there is a
contradictory claim being made that that
is not her handwriting so let's evaluate
this this would be
uh
this is specific and substantive so and
it's sourced so there's no issue here
with evaluating it abc news reports
trump white house attorney disputes
cassidy hutchinson's testimony about a
handwritten note
former trump white house lawyer eric
hirschman is claiming that a handwritten
note regarding a potential statement for
then president donald trump to release
during the january sixth attack was
written by him during a meeting at the
white house that afternoon not by
cassidy hutchinson sources familiar with
the matter tell abc news so what's this
all about
at tuesday's january 6 committee hearing
liz chaney displayed a note
which hutchinson said i wrote that
she she saw it and she said that's my
handwriting i wrote that
sources familiar with the matter say
that eric hershman an attorney had
previously told the committee he wrote
the note
a spokesperson for hirschmann said to
abc news tuesday night quote the
handwritten note that cassidy hutchinson
testified was written by her was in fact
written by eric hirschman on january 6
2021
all sources with direct knowledge and
law enforcement have and will confirm
that it was written by mr hirschman
at the hearing on tuesday hutchinson
testified about the note quote that's a
note that i wrote at the direction of
the chief of staff on january 6 likely
around 3 o'clock liz cheney asked and
it's written on the chief of staff note
card but that's your handwriting ms
hutchinson
and ms hutchinson said that's my
handwriting
okay
this is a specific disagreement
and it is not really subject to the
squishiness of some of the other claims
well
we're willing to testify that the
claim about trump trying to grab the
wheel didn't happen well how can you
testify something didn't happen if you
okay that's sort of like squishy and
subject to some kind of interpretation
this is just like whose handwriting is
it who wrote the note
and if she didn't write the note you
know people tend to to know their own
handwriting when i look you know down
here i have all sorts of cop i have
copious notes on a legal pad i can
immediately see that this is all my
handwriting
if i saw different handwriting it would
be very evident to me people tend to be
very well acquainted with their own
handwriting she said it was her
handwriting someone else is saying no i
wrote that well let's figure it out
and if she was wrong about that we would
want to know did she deliberately lie
about that was she confused about her
own handwriting which would be weird
it would be something to figure out but
understand
that every aspect of this
is that is being used simply to attack
her by people who barely even know who
she is as an example sean hannity last
night seized on this entire handwriting
thing and he said did catherine really
write it her name's cassidy they don't
even know her name they don't care they
just want to attack bring in a
handwriting i'd bring in handwriting
experts and they can determine was it
hershman or was it the the woman from
yesterday catherine
right was it catherine who wrote it well
sean it was not catherine who wrote it
because no one named catherine is
involved here they don't even know her
name but to the extent that this is a
substantive claim is it her handwriting
is it someone else's eric hirschman says
i wrote that
let's figure out who wrote it and then
let's figure out what the confusion is
no problem with that whatsoever all
right major steps being taken now the
january 6 committee has subpoenaed
trump's former white house lawyer pat
chipoloni patra bologna is a name
that made headlines on tuesday in part
because the closed captioning
could not handle the name pat chipoloni
at one point it uh the closed captioning
during tuesday's hearing said patsy
baloney
or patsy bologna in other cases so
everybody knows the name pat chipoloni
now patricia poloni has been subpoenaed
to testify uh the guardian reports
january 6 committee subpoenas former
white house counsel patricia poloni
donald trump's former council was a key
witness to some of the ex-president's
most brazen schemes to overturn the 2020
election why do we care about this we
care about this because many of the
claims being made
by others who
if we make this attempt to steal the
election well it would be really great
to get him under oath did he say that
did he believe that what was his uh
assessment of what donald trump was
trying to do
the house select committee has issued a
subpoena
compelling him to testify about at least
three parts of trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 election results
the subpoena marked a dramatic
escalation for the panel and showed its
resolve in seeking to obtain inside
information about how trump sought to
return himself to office
mr chipoloni repeatedly raised legal and
other concerns about trump's activities
on january 6 and the days that proceeded
the committee needs to hear from him on
the record as other former white house
counsels have done in other
congressional investigations
chipoloni was a key witness to some of
trump's most brazen schemes which the
select committee said in its hearings
was part of a sprawling and potentially
unlawful multi-pronged strategy
culminating in the capital attack
chipoloni has information about trump's
push to send fake slates of electors to
congress the subpoena letter said
so is he going to testify
um
we don't know
every indication so far has been that
folks like chipoloni have no interest in
being put under oath and answering
direct questions about what took place
on january 6 january 5th and the days
approaching it um he should testify i
hope he cooperates i hope he doesn't
take the steve bannon root and um if we
are able to you know the problem we're
having right now
is you get someone
at every instance
the the sequence is like this
there's the initial sort of framework
for the january 6 committee republicans
say we don't like it we're not
participating okay so then it forces
democrats to say are there any
republicans willing to be on this
committee and adam kinzinger says i'll
do it and liz cheney says i'll do it and
then republicans say well look they they
barely have republicans on the committee
well but that's by your choice
then they get witnesses to testify
uh cassidy hutchinson and others testify
and they make claims under oath under
tremendous legal pressure and a
tremendous societal pressure she now
needs security on and on and on getting
threats
and then in the media
oh well we're willing to have a
different uh to put put forth our
perspective which contradicts cassidy
hutchinson's okay we'll show up and do
it under oath well they're not willing
to have us yes they are
they said at the end of the hearing
anyone else who has light to shed on
these incidents please come forward we
would like you to testify well where are
they it's now been 48 hours nobody has
been scheduled to testify as of yet
bring them in
and so there's this constant
attempt to say well here's a claim made
under oath here's something someone said
to someone on twitter they they cancel
out so we don't know what the truth is
well no hold on a second the statements
made under oath
attributed to individuals should carry
more weight than the random musings of
someone saying i would show up and say
something different
show up
take the oath and say something
different and then we will evaluate it
let me know on twitter where you can
find me at d pacman do you think any of
these supposed contradictors
are actually going to show up and make
contradictory statements under oath let
me know we'll take a quick break and be
right back the david pakman show depends
on the support of our audience our
primary source of funding is the
membership program we have on our
website joinpacman.com we do an extra
show every day called the bonus show for
our members oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
well okay i wouldn't call it quite so
bad it's just an extra show alex but
thank you you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting 22
to get a sizable discount off of the
cost of a membership
hope to see you
on today's bonus show jenny thomas's
lawyer says she's just too stressed out
to testify because of what's going on in
the united states today yes it's uh
beyond parody so let's back up a little
bit clarence thomas is a supreme court
justice ginny thomas is the wife of
clarence thomas jenny thomas we now know
was very much involved in the fake
elector scheme of the 2022 election
trying to send fake electors to
washington dc
to vote for trump instead of joe biden
despite joe biden having won their state
this includes arizona she was heavily
involved in the um uh lead up to the
january sixth rally that donald trump
did before the riot ginny thomas is very
involved
and this also puts clarence thomas in a
potentially compromising position where
many are saying he should really recuse
himself from anything even remotely
having to do with the 2020 election the
january 6 committee now wants to hear
from her and her lawyer says guys she's
just too stressed out and this is only
days after she said she was eager to
testify yet again
oh i want to tell my side okay we'll
show up and swear an oath oh i'm too
stressed now i can't do it business
insider reports jenny thomas's lawyer
tries to get her out of the january 6
panel testimony saying it's been a
particularly stressful time amid all of
these supreme court rulings you've got
to be kidding me
the attorney for ginny thomas the wife
of supreme court justice clarence thomas
questioned the need for her testimony
before the january 6 committee and said
it had been a quote particularly
stressful time oh poor thing amid recent
supreme court rulings the house
committee investigating the capital riot
requested a voluntary interview with
thomas earlier this month over her
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
she didn't formally accept the
invitation but she said two weeks ago
she quote can't wait to speak to the
panel
okay
but in an eight-page letter sent on
tuesday thomas's attorney mark palletta
wrote he had quote serious concerns
about the interview asked the committee
to quote provide a better justification
for why her testimony would be relevant
and added in his letter i would also
note that this has been a particularly
stressful time as the thomases have been
subjected to an avalanche of death
threats and other abuse by the
unprecedented assault on the
conservative supreme court justices and
their families oh guys it's just too
stressful for her right now but of
course remember jenny thomas
14 days ago i can't wait to talk to the
january 6 committee and we'll quote
clear up misconceptions it sounds like
two weeks ago
she saw the opportunity to testify
or r it wasn't even to testify it was an
informal interview to speak to the
january 6 committee
as maybe a stress-reducing thing i would
love to show up it would be so good for
me
to reduce and clear up misconceptions
about my involvement cut to cut to this
week oh it's just way too stressful for
her way way way too stressful well
why not clear up the misconceptions
maybe the misconceptions aren't really
misconceptions maybe she really was as
involved as it's believed in the
attempts to overturn the 2020 election
did clarence thomas say oh hell no you
can't do that that's insane
did her lawyer say you know if you give
this informal interview the next step is
the committee might say well we need you
to testify under oath and then if you
don't then they might subpoena you and
maybe the conversation would reveal
additional information that's bad for
clarence thomas
guys she's married to a supreme court
justice
she must have known
that this all could lead towards sworn
testimony in which she would be bound to
tell the truth and this is straight out
of the trump playbook remember that one
of the classics of the trump playbook is
the principle it was often trump who
would do it he would say hell yeah i'll
show up
i'll clear all this up and it's because
trump thinks
he's smarter than everybody in the room
trump thinks he can lie and give his
false version of events and everybody's
going to fall for it nobody's going to
realize that the guy is lying and then
lawyers say oh there is no way you're
showing up in testifying under oath
remember that with the russia probe this
was a thing trump kept saying i can show
up and i'm going to tell him what's what
and of course every lawyer said oh dear
god
this guy lies uncontrollably if he shows
up and lies that's what others are
getting indicted and charged for and
found guilty of you can't do that you
tell everyone just how eager you are to
share your information you tell
everybody how eager you are to clarify
and then later someone else says oh yeah
no
here's the thing she's really stressed
out guys she can't show up and that's
exactly what happened with trump in the
russia probe and listen i'm open to
seeing do these secret service agents
testify do other aids to high-level
trump staff come in and contradict the
testimony of cassidy hutchinson bring
them in put them under oath and then
we'll keep it we'll consider it on an
equal playing field otherwise it's just
media nonsense and the latest is ginny
thomas is just too stressed out to show
up and clear up everything just we're
wrong about everything we've said about
her and she would love to clear it up
but it's just too stressful for her
right now give me a break
donald trump
is now apparently turning not only on
fox news but also on newsmax donald
trump appeared on newsmax last night
and he said the election is stolen
and fox news no longer talks about it
and newsmax no longer talks about it he
says i guess that they're afraid
and he even says to the newsmax host i
bet you guys are going to cut what i'm
saying right now and the host says no no
no we're not going to cut it check this
out trump's furious with anyone who
won't uncritically repeat his baseless
and false claims check this out look at
the dishonesty of this committee right
they don't talk about any of the things
that refute january 6. they don't talk
about the election numbers they don't
analyze the election the people were
there because the election was rigged
and stolen
so what they should be doing is trying
to convince people that it wasn't you do
that through analyzing the numbers they
don't want to do that in fact they don't
even want to hear that
and fox doesn't put it on and by the way
you people don't put it on either you're
afraid of being sued or something i
don't know someday you'll have to
explain that this is yeah well at a
certain point you can only lie so much
before you're potentially in legal
jeopardy that's true it is everything
trump is saying isn't true
in fact they'll probably cut what i'm
saying of course i know i don't know of
course this will be on wake up don't let
tomorrow morning sir absolutely not get
it done
get it done fast before chris sees it
okay
but
might cut it out and let's just see i
hope they put it on yeah but this was
about a rigged and stolen election now
that's not actually what the committee
is about
understand it's when trump says
the committee won't investigate this
other thing
it's sort of like saying this committee
refuses to talk about the rash of thefts
of catalytic converters from priuses
well okay
the the that's not the focus of the
committee
the thefts of catalytic converters also
happen to happens to be a real thing
whereas the uh theft of the election is
imaginary but it's not what the
committee is there to do
that millions and millions of people
felt is true right and of course facts
don't care about your feelings but trump
continues to repeat people feel the
election was stolen people feel it was
stolen and fox news no longer talks
about it and newsmax no longer talks
about it they talked about it for months
they talk about it for months and
there's nothing there now
what trump is really saying when he says
this is
media outlets that are supposed to be
friendly to me aren't doing enough heavy
lifting on the lies that i am trying to
perpetuate
that's the translation for what trump is
saying here
interestingly trump was also asked
during this interview about the
allegations made by cassidy hutchinson
that he lunged at a secret service agent
um and tried to commandeer the vehicle
trump's explanation for why it's not
true
it's sort of that he's too fat to do the
thing he was accused of doing listen
carefully here and they put her on and
they don't even confirm it with the
secret service the secret service people
in the car
said this didn't happen but but you
don't even need that now remember
they have not testified under oath there
is a report
through the grapevine that some secret
service agent is willing to contradict
some of what cassidy hutchinson said
none of it has actually happened yet but
okay let's continue who would do that i
would
i would grab a secret service person by
the throat i don't even know if it's
possible certainly not in the beast it's
very hard even in one of the suvs it's
very hard for another reason these guys
lift 350 pounds right right
so when trump says these guys lift 350
pounds and i don't what he's saying is
he's out of shape what he's saying is
he's obese what he's saying is it would
be a stupid thing to do
to try to do anything but trump does
stupid things all the time narcissists
overstate their or over
they over believe they are falsely
confident in all of their abilities not
only their intelligence but maybe also
their physical abilities and by the way
notice that what was said there the
beast versus suvs initially the claim
was in the beast meaning the
presidential limo trump is sitting so
far from the driver that he couldn't do
the thing cassidy hutchinson accused him
of doing but when you look at the video
of that day if i recall correctly trump
is actually leaving in an suv it's a
different vehicle completely so when
laura ingram and others say you can't do
that in the limo
the video seems to show trump in an suv
all right let's look at the last bit of
this v tonight it seemed like it was
pretty smooth yeah i know like
it's fine i mean like but you know these
are
people these are great people these are
great people they've devoted their lives
to it and i think they were very
embarrassed by it because it makes them
sound terrible tony ornato and bobby
engel are well great i know their
records sterling they are sterling and i
was very nice that they came to my
defense i thought it was incredible
actually now remember
there are allegations that they would
come to trump's defense they have not
actually done it yet in any kind of
significant way uh because
you know some whack job can say this
stuff and get away with it and other
things that i wanted guns at my rally
okay now i'm speaking why would i want
guns i don't want people having standing
with guns
in my rally oh so guns are dangerous now
wow okay i mean if he believes guns
everywhere make everybody safer why
wouldn't he want the gut it's all a
verbal ink blot test but trump now upset
with fox that they won't do his carry
water on his election lies upset that
newsmax won't even though they kind of
do but just not to that degree and trump
essentially saying i'm not in shape
enough to do the thing that i was
accused of doing
make of it what you will we'll have
these clips on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with joe
henrich who is professor of human
evolutionary biology at harvard
university and also author of the book
the weirdest people in the world how the
west became psychologically peculiar and
particularly prosperous it's really
great having you on today i appreciate
your time
yeah good to be with you
so let's first talk about weird is an
acronym w-e-i-r-d
for western educated industrialized rich
and democratic so how did you first
start to sort of uh think about this
this group of people as a group of
people and sort of what the defining
characteristics are
yeah so uh around 2006 or so i began
working with two cultural psychologists
steve heinen arnor and zion at the
university of british columbia and you
know we had come together over lunch and
stuff and began to talk about our
research and what we each had realized
someone independently was not only was
there a cultural variation around the
world and
key aspects of psychology but that the
populations most commonly studied by
psychologists and others were unusual
when seated in that global perspective
so they were often at the tail end of
the distribution or you know
distinctively set apart from other
populations
so we came up with the idea of writing a
paper together the weirdest people in
the world meant to raise an alarm kind
of a methodological methodological
concern
aimed at psychologists and others
that they were over generalizing from
the populations that they studied that
they they couldn't make assumptions
about human behavior by studying
american undergraduates or people online
people from those sources and then as a
way of referring to the populations most
commonly studied by researchers we came
up with the acronym weird um just as a
way and it's meant as a
consciousness-raising device to kind of
remind researchers that they they should
be cautious about generalizing
so when we talk about the uh
characteristics
western
makes sense educated makes sense
industrialized
rich and democratic when we talk about
rich are we talking about rich at a
global scale or are we saying even
within these western countries we're
talking about the rich
well i mean what we had in mind was
mostly psychologists were sampling
undergrad at the time they were mostly
sampling undergraduates from a small
handful of countries so the u.s canada
a couple places in europe australia
places like that so you know to the
degree to which american undergraduates
tend to be disproportionately sampled
from the middle and upper class yeah so
in that case it leaves out
um
lower ses and then of course globally
those are among the richest countries in
the world
before we move on to some of the other
aspects of your research it's often
repeated and things that are often
repeated aren't necessarily true but
it's often repeated that
um
if you compare folks
from the large cities in the united
states to the rest of the us and then
compare them to people from places like
london and paris etc that the folks from
large cities across these countries are
much more similar than those within the
united states living living in urban
versus rural settings for example
do you think in your research does that
sound right to you or does that maybe
miss some important things
well definitely misses some important
things so uh in in putting together the
evidence that you know we were able to
gather you can compare
uh you know corporate managers or
executives from around the world working
all working at you know leading uh
productive companies and you can detect
the same kind of psychological variation
you can get if you compare you know the
the
groups from lower socioeconomic status
or you know more representative
populations of these countries
can you talk a little bit about you know
in in the title of the book
you use the term psychologically
peculiar peculiar can just mean unique
and different but it can also mean that
the sort of something maybe that we
would identify as strange or unusual
what are the psychological peculiarities
of of this group that is often the
source for for studies
yeah so the key thing i wanted to focus
on was trying to understand the
psychological variation we find around
across populations around the globe so
some of the key dimensions that emerged
were one
is a kind of psychological cluster or
complex called individualism
that's associated with how people think
about themselves about overconfidence
and self-esteem
and the role of guilt versus shame
and so there's a whole cluster there
where
uh people in weird societies tend to
think about themselves as
unitary individual decision makers
rather than nodes in a social network
they tend to be overconfident they tend
to have concerns about guilt but shame
is relatively unimportant
this goes along with another pattern
which is analytic versus holistic
thinking so there's tends to be an
inclination towards more analytic
thinking so breaking problems down into
parts assigning properties to those
parts and then reasoning from that point
of view as opposed to looking at the
relationships among parts um to to make
explanations so we find lots of
variation there
uh the use of intentionality and moral
judgments to be another one so lots of
westerners really think intentions are
important but in other places you know
intentions don't seem to be important at
all at least in making some moral
judgments
um
moral universalism so the degree to
which you think everyone should be
judged by the same moral standards
versus moral particularism where you
make a difference between how people
within some circle uh should be judged
versus people outside that circle trust
in strangers as another important one
things like that
what are the sources of these
peculiarities i mean is it is it media
is it the characteristics themselves
like being you know rich or
industrialized or whatever the case may
be
does religion and and or churches
play a role what what what causes this
well i mean there's probably lots of
factors that affect uh overall global
psychological variation but in the book
i was particularly interested in trying
to understand why it was that european
and european descent populations became
particularly
individualistic and particularly
have a strong impersonal pro-sociality
so this trust in cooperation with
strangers which should be contrasted
with a more interpersonal pro-sociality
where people are are much more
cooperative and positively inclined
towards people they know people they
have relationships with that kind of
thing within group loyalty
so um
the the case that i make is that much of
the kind of unusual nature of european
society as it emerged in the last 500
years comes from
uh a
particular set of taboos and
prescriptions that one branch of
christianity the one that evolves into
the roman catholic church began to
promulgate in late antiquity and
eventually
although gradually spreads throughout
many parts of western europe and
transforms the intensive complex kinship
organizations that you would find in
many pre-christian european societies
and breaks them down into monogamous
nuclear
families
and then this opens the door for other
kinds of institutions impersonal
institutions eventually things like
democracy and western law and whatnot
but initially things like guilds
universities monasteries
that were organized differently and
built around notions of individuals
trying to attract individuals so it
really puts
these populations on a different kind of
cultural evolutionary trajectory than
we've we see in many societies around
the world and back in history so in if i
understand correctly even though today
in the united states for example
roman catholics are not a majority the
evolution and growth of the roman
catholic church starting 500 years ago
in europe
led to
in a sense psychological changes which
include acceptance of certain types of
relationships to institutions that are
still very relevant today in terms of
how this group you study relates to the
world
that's right you should think of that
the stuff the catholic church did as
initiating a kind of cultural
evolutionary process and then these
principles get to varying degrees
embedded in secular institutions and
become part of the general cultural
milieu
one of the one of the cases i make in
the book is that this process led to the
emergence of protestantism so you know
there's this goes on for a thousand
years before martin luther and others um
initiate this protestant reformation
which of course is a is a constellation
a mosaic of different religious
movements that are rebelling against the
catholic church
but i mean they have sort of super weird
characteristics in the sense that
they're really focused on
uh mental states the role of
intentionality centrality on the
individual emphasis on hard work
deferral of gratification
uh
so
it is only further accentuate some of
the basic characteristics that had been
developing prior to that you know some
of the characteristics you write about
and that you've spoken about high level
of individualism
um
maybe
analytical to some degree in a way
that's not as common in other societies
or in other parts of society
non-conformism etc i will often hear
from people when they visit a country
that is outside of of this group you
know friends who have done work in
southeast asia or have gone to africa
etc and they seem to very quickly pick
up on the fact that there's just sort of
like something different about the
perspective on the world around them
that has to do with
uh some of the traits that you're
pointing out here so it seems as though
part of the reason many who are part of
this weird group aren't aware of this is
they're just around people like
themselves all the time in other words
we have the ability to notice when folks
are different we maybe just aren't
spending enough time around them but
that once you do you realize that there
is there is some kind of cultural
difference here
yeah absolutely so i mean that's the
real value to
to traveling and living in other
societies so you know uh i come up as an
anthropologist so as a cultural
anthropologist i i got to live in
amazonia in small communities
i did a long stretch of field work in
the south pacific on remote islands and
you know really tried to dig in and live
among the people and to the degree to
which other people did that for other
reasons it really does kind of you know
it's like a fish out of water or
something you really then begin to
notice that lack of water around you or
the
striking difference that you don't see
unless
unless you get removed from the water
is it hard to understand some of these
things just by being told about them
because what my mind is going to is if
you read some of jared diamond's books
for example where he talks extensively
about his time spent in the pacific with
the maori people etc
when you just read his descriptions of
the culture yes it's different
but i can only imagine that the degree
to which you can really feel that
partially has to be from actually being
there thousands of miles from where you
normally are and sort of being told
about this phenomena can only really do
so much
yeah i mean uh i there's different ways
to get at it so of course you know
living with people and learning the
language and trying to really engage in
the society is the is the best way to
get a feel for it yeah i mean there are
you know
i guess not you know things like novels
can try to bring you and put you in the
shoes of someone living in that society
you know an honor society where you're
very concerned about uh maintaining your
honor because that protects your family
and it's core to your identity as a
person
um so so that's another way and then of
course
you know some amount of travel can at
least give you a feel for it
are any of the distinctions that you
study
can can value judgments be assigned to
them to some degree in terms of either
what's quote better for the individuals
within or for
the groups and societies at a whole or
or is this merely we're observing
differences and that's as far as it goes
well so my mission in the book was just
to
well kind of start out by documenting
the differences but the thing i was
really interested in doing is explaining
the variation and cueing to my readers
many of which i sort of assumed as i as
i wrote the book would be mostly weird
so i was trying to jar them
in ways that would make them recognize
the water so to speak so recognize the
sort of psychological differences so
when i talk about analytic thinking you
know analytic thinking can be very
powerful breaking things down into parts
and assigning them properties it's
really the basis of how you know what
physics is right break everything down
into particles and give them charges or
uh spin or charge or something like that
um and then explain everything from that
psychologists give peace people
personalities and try to explain that
economists do a similar thing so it's
very powerful
but you can miss the forest so like some
of the subsections in the book are like
missing the forest reminding people that
if you're too much of an analytic
thinker um
you can miss how all the parts fit
together and how the relationships are
so important
so for example when you do when
psychologists do work on what leads to
effective problem solving in teams the
best teams at solving problems and
engaging in creativity are teams that
have a mixture of analytic and holistic
thinkers so you need both
growth groups towards the end of the
book i really emphasize the role of uh
embracing cultural differences for
generating innovation so most most
innovations are recombinations of
existing ideas and so the degree to what
you can get people with very different
ideas different ways of seeing the world
to interact in mutually trusting and
potentially cooperative and beneficial
ways you're just going to generate more
innovation so one of the things i've
been researching lately is the is the
degree to which immigration energized
economic growth and innovation patenting
within the united states
you talk um in the book about delayed
gratification and differences um uh
among different societies on delayed
gratification many of us have probably
heard of these studies that were done on
little kids where
you know they say well i'm gonna put a
cookie in front of you and i'm gonna
leave and if you don't eat it i'll give
you a second cookie later and you kind
of evaluate you know who does what um
i think to some degree
in weird societies as as defined by you
being able to delay gratification is
seen as objectively good
and that may not always be the case but
it seems as though it's seen as sort of
like a virtue in some sense being able
to delay gratification and one of the
things you you find is that
not delaying gratification is more
common among non-weird people
is that a place where there's actually
sort of like logical explanations for
why it's not objectively better to delay
gratification if you consider the
context maybe
yeah so uh that's a great case because
there people do have a sense that that's
sort of a virtue that's very much a
protestant virtue actually
so you get that right out of
protestantism um
so the way to think about it is that
these aspects of our psychology are
adapted to the institutional and
ecological environments that we have to
confront
so
they did chris blattman and colleagues
political scientists and economists the
university of chicago
did this research in liberia
where they they
basically created a training course to
try to increase the self-regulation of
poor men to try to make them more
patient and more willing to defer
gratification
uh the training worked and they were
able to show that on the psychological
tests men were willing to defer
gratification more and initially this
seemed to be a big success because the
men were able to begin to develop little
nest eggs of savings and things like
that right okay so that's working but
then it turns out that because the
environment is so unstable the men would
get robbed or they'd get shaken down by
the police or something would happen and
they'd lose their complete nest egg so
they wouldn't get the pleasure that
would have come from
indulging in that
so that that's one way and you need to a
stable environment where you can
preserve that savings and you need the
chance that you're going to be alive
when you get a chance to take advantage
of it otherwise it's better to to
consume now when you're sure you're
going to get something out of it the
other thing that that varies across
societies is in a lot of cases
if i accumulate much my my relatives are
going to come and ask for it essentially
so we'll die there'll be a funeral or
there'll be a wedding
so what i do
one way to deal with a any kind of
rising surplus is just to give it away
have a party or give it to others and
the way people think about that or maybe
not consciously but the way it ends up
functioning is that you're storing your
surplus in the good will and
relationships you have with others right
when you're in need you don't have to
have a nest egg your nest egg is
scattered amongst all these
friends and relatives and close contacts
that you've cultivated over long periods
of time yeah that's super interesting
and to some degree i've studied that a
little bit in hasidic jewish communities
uh and there's a there that that
phenomena is very very notable there
interestingly enough um the book is
fascinating it's called the weirdest
people in the world how the west became
psychologically peculiar and
particularly prosperous we've been
speaking with the book's author harvard
university professor joe henrich joe
really appreciate your time today
okay well it's great to be with you
so rudy giuliani is not having a
particularly good week first he claimed
that he was almost killed at a uh
grocery store then the surveillance
video came out and someone patted him on
the back he claimed that he was hit so
hard that the person standing next to
him almost fell down and then the video
came out and all of it was untrue so
that was not a great start to the week
for rudy giuliani then cassidy
hutchinson testified that rudy giuliani
wanted a pardon from donald trump around
the time of the january 6th riots and
rudy giuliani
accidentally admitted to that request
and i'm going to show you the message he
subsequently deleted the tweet so let's
go piece by piece first and foremost
here is cassidy hutchinson on tuesday
saying rudy giuliani and mark meadows
they both wanted pardons related to
january 6th did rudy giuliani ever
suggest that he was interested in
receiving a presidential pardon related
to january 6th
he did
miss hutchinson
did white house chief of staff mark
meadows ever indicate that he was
interested in receiving a presidential
pardon related to january 6th
mr meadows did seek that pardon yes
so very very clear rudy wanted a pardon
and mark meadows wanted a pardon okay
fine
so tuesday night rudy giuliani tweets
once again the january 6th committee of
russian collusion liars suborned perjury
from cassidy hutchinson i specifically
told president trump i did not need want
or need a pardon
i also have witnesses to corroborate
that she and the committee are
perpetrating yet another lie okay
and then on wednesday
rudy doubled down
but he unfortunately admits to the
entire thing
rudy tweets the january 6th which hunt
cabal has now exceeded even its prior
fraudulent
the la
strange grammar okay the last witness
was a reckless liar contrary to her
false testimony she was never present
when i asked for a partner
uh did
she says that you slapped your wife sir
she was not there when i slapped my wife
i mean i didn't slap my wife
then rudy says actually i told the
president i did not want or need one he
then subsequently
deleted that tweet
not going particularly well for rudy
giuliani now one explanation would be
he's just confused what he meant by she
wasn't there when i asked for a pardon
is he never asked for a pardon maybe
that's actually what he meant but it
doesn't look particularly good when you
say she wasn't there when i did the
things she accuses me of doing and then
you delete the tweet uh all very very
strange and again
put the people under oath get rudy there
and have them testify under oath get
everybody there and have them contradict
her claims under oath i don't for a
second listen
when you're asked about things
from a year and a half ago
you are stressed now when you're being
asked the questions it was a stressful
time then
i am completely sympathetic to the
notion
that there will be details that could be
off in this testimony i think that
applies to the friendly witnesses i
think that applies to the hostile
witnesses i think that that's perfectly
plausible
but right now we have the under oath
testimony of a very composed cassidy
hutchinson
and then we have the confusing and
contradictory
and sometimes bizarre admissions and
subsequent deletions
uh reacting to her claims put these
people under oath and we will evaluate
their claims with all of the same
consideration and seriousness that we're
evaluating the claims made by cassidy
hutchinson period
all right this is this is really weird
many of you have asked me to react to
this
podcaster joe rogan on whose program
i've appeared two times
now seems to essentially be endorsing
the dangerous radical unhinged
republican governor of florida ron
desantis now we're going to look at what
joe rogan said
but one of the important things to keep
in mind is
it's not just about oh rogan likes
desantis there's another aspect to this
which is rogan has been insisting that
he's like a progressive guy that his
policy ideas are most in line with
someone like a bernie sanders so
when you see someone who says i i really
am like a bernie guy in a lot of ways
when you see them say i like desantis
you have to ask questions like
is it not true that his policies most
align with bernie because bernie and
desantis are basically polar opposites
or does he not even really understand
what these people's policies are and
he's going on personality
i don't know the answer to any of these
questions but let's take a look at the
video clip here is rogan saying
desantis desantis didn't elon musk uh
come out recently for desantis yeah i
think ron desantis would work as a good
president i think i mean what he's done
for florida has been admirable look i
feel like i'm doing breaking news right
now that wasn't even on purpose
i feel like what he did for florida a
lot of people gave him a lot of grief
but ultimately he was correct he was
correct when it comes to like deaths he
was correct when it comes to protecting
all vulnerable populations he was
correct in terms of distribution of
monoclonal antibodies and he was furious
when the government tried to pull those
they were trying to pull very effective
treatments
you know he is just as a quick factor
the government wasn't trying to pull it
what the government started to realize
was that its effectiveness was
diminishing and it may not be the best
course of action in some cases but it's
it's
it really has nothing to do with the
bigger picture here let's listen not
perfect he's a human being but um what
he's done is stand up for freedoms and
people think that so this this was some
weird gaslighting [ __ ] that went on
where people equated freedom and saying
the word freedom to like right wing
bigotry and hate is so strange well
sometimes that is exactly what they
meant by it so there's two parts okay
how did desantis do as florida governor
and then what about the prospect of ron
desantis as president of the united
states so florida
despite being one of the top tourism
states in the country no thanks to
desantis like it's not because of
desantis that people go
to the gulf coast of florida to the
beaches to the atlantic coast of florida
to the beaches to the various um theme
parks and resorts in orlando to miami
beach that has nothing to do with the
sandisk florida has some great tourism
attractions and despite that florida
ranks 33rd in opportunity 26th in crime
41st in access to health care 20
of floridians have no health insurance
and importantly that's all been pretty
similar with desantis as governor so
desantis has handed this tourism-rich
state
and he doesn't improve any of those
disastrous numbers
now in terms of the political positions
of ron desantis
first of all ron desantis is against
legalizing recreational marijuana isn't
this like a non-starter for rogan rogan
correctly supports legalization i agree
with rogan on that completely
the desantis view on that issue is so
antiquated wouldn't it be a
disqualifying position for someone like
joe rogan evaluating a candidate does
rogan know about that maybe he does
maybe he doesn't desantis is just
straight up against abortion he just
he's just against abortion period that's
it
another retrograde
antiquated uh world view um
rogan has daughters wouldn't he want in
certain situations that to be an option
at least if his daughters ever needed to
avail themselves of such a medical
treatment
it just none of it's making any sense
and then of course you just go deeper
and desantis is wrong on you know all
but like a few issues that he comes
across desantis was against the iran
nuclear deal
he said it was a bad deal that would
degrade national security in fact the
deal worked really well
until donald trump stepped up and just
said we're out of the deal even though
iran didn't violate the deal i mean just
terrible what donald trump did the deal
was working fine it wasn't no deal is
perfect but it was working well
desantis is opposed to all gun safety
regulations the nra has raided desantis
as an a-plus now maybe rogan likes that
for me it's completely despicable
desantis called for a full and complete
repeal of obamacare with of course like
all of these republicans
no real substantive and plausible plan
for how to get people health care and as
i mentioned 20 percent of floridians
have no health insurance one out of five
floridians does not have health
insurance desantis was opposed to
deferred action for childhood arrivals
that's known as daca daca refers to
you're seven years old your parents come
to the united states illegally it's not
your fault you're seven you go where
your parents take you you then go to
school and then you go to high school
and
and what we should be doing is saying
this is really your country
you should be allowed to stay we're
going to defer action because you were a
childhood arrival
even many republicans are okay with that
desantis is against it and desantis has
a zero rating from the human rights
campaign for his voting record on
lgbt-related issues and legislation
everything i know about rogan is that
rogan is not homophobic and that rogan
believes that everybody should be
treated with dignity and respect and is
for gay marriage and on and on and
desantis has a zero rating so when it
comes to rogan on something like this
does rogan not know about the political
positions does rogan just go on
personality does rogan just go on
rhetoric i don't know the answer but it
is bizarre
for someone who says i'm like most
aligned with someone like bernie to say
desantis would be a good president it's
weird and i don't know what the
explanation is and i don't know how much
rogan knows about what ron desantis does
and stands for but that's where we are
right now and of course rogan's got a
huge audience there are people who will
hear this and go yeah i guess desantis i
don't know desantis is good as i've said
before desantis is like a trump
but he's less incompetent
and that makes him much more dangerous
scary stuff
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a caller
dipping us further into the black hole
of spanish pronunciations
that i sometimes do on the
show david sir
this is a reply to your discussion
of the pronunciation of spanish language
words please in my experience it's a
no-win situation
i have a friend
felipe cervantes right who is originally
from chile
yet he often argues
with my friend ernesto delgado
who is from mexico right about who is
the best chess player in history
felipe believes it is jose capablanca
right but ernesto disagrees so what are
you going to do right
in the end though they were able to
settle their differences over some um
and enchilada
so all's well that ends well i suppose
all right take care my friend bye yeah
no i understand that you know it's it's
one of these things where if you say
cappa blanca you look at dude don't you
speak spanish why why are you saying
capablanca
and then if you say capablanca then
people say dude that's really jarring
why if you're speaking english you don't
need to do that it is an absolute no win
it is the black hole
of spanish pronunciation thank you very
much for pointing it out we have a great
bonus show for you today but sadly the
stories are not exactly fun stories
a woman was shot dead in manhattan
while pushing a baby stroller
horrifying story which we will talk
about
four individuals have already been found
and charged in that mass casualty
tractor trailer death from texas that i
spoke to you about yesterday
and we are going to compare
the sentence handed down the prison
sentence hand it down to gilain maxwell
compared to the sentence handed down to
r kelly many writing in and saying david
it seems as though r kelly got a
disproportionately heavy sentence
compared to maxwell based on what they
were charged with
what's going on here we're going to talk
about it and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com
i will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise on tomorrow's program